die kunden und dann geht es los ja
das lockern lockt mehr als der lockdown
klar aber öffnen während die
infektionszahlen wieder steigen zwar
noch langsam aber vielleicht bald immer
schneller
selbst beim allheilmittel impfen ertönt
ein vielstimmiger chor die lage ist
verzwickt und morgen soll entschieden
werden
im debatte und öffnung streit wo bleibt
die korona strategie jetzt in der
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio georg streiter
ist bei uns journalist politik berater
der agentur streiter und streiter und
sie waren stellvertretender
regierungssprecher hier in berlin den
jahren von 2011 bis 2018
alexander kissler ist von der neuen
zürcher zeitung aus dem berliner büro
zugeschaltet lisa federle sie ist
notärztin und pandemie beauftragt für
die stadt tübingen und schließlich
thorsten lehrer professor für klinische
pharmazie an der universität des
saarlandes und sie haben den sogenannten
coffee simulator entwickelt herr lehrer
das ist ein rechenmodell mit dem man
versucht die entwicklung der kurve
erkrankung vorauszusehen einzuschätzen
auch mit belastbaren zahlen dann die
politik zu füttern lassen sich denn da
jetzt schon prognosen ableiten wie sich
die infektionszahlen sagen wir in der
zeit bis ostern entwickeln könnten bei
uns auch anhand oder aufgrund der
drohenden mutationen ja wann es genau
solche dinge wie zum beispiel die
mutation oder mutter nach mit
eingebauter auch in die entwicklung die
zukünftige entwicklung spielt die
zukünftige entwicklung hängt jetzt
natürlich sehr stark davon ab was jetzt
morgen beschlossen wird was aber
momentan sehen ist eigentlich wenn die
infektion so weitergehen und der locker
und so fortgeschritten voll beibehalten
wird wieder aktuell
er ist dann würde mir also sehen dass
die zinsen weiter ansteigen und dass wir
also trotzdem lockt also kein weiteres
absinken der inzidenz mehr zu erwarten
haben pro federle zu ihren funktionen
ich gerade genannt habe gehört auch noch
dazu dass sie in tübingen eine mobile
arztpraxis entwickelt haben um
obdachlose und flüchtlinge zu
unterstützen und das jetzt
umfunktioniert haben in ein schnelltest
labor steht und fällt denn die korona
entwicklung in den nächsten wochen mit
der massenhaften verfügbarkeit dieser
schnelltests also ich glaube dass das
eine bedingung ist um überhaupt öffnen
zu können wir haben jetzt den typen
beispielsweise vor drei wochen schon
angefangen die lehrer einzuladen und die
kindergarten und kindergärtnerinnen und
die testen sich jetzt selber regelmäßig
in der schule und auch die schüler und
damit hat man dann so eine gewisse
übersicht wie sich das alles entwickelt
wir testen aber schon seit wir haben
angefangen im oktober mit testen und
testen seit 26
november regelmäßig fünf tage auf
marktplatz bieten kostenlose schnelltest
an und das ist ein sensationeller erfolg
gewesen wir waren bei 20.000 tests
inzwischen die wir durchgeführt haben
bei symptomen losen menschen und haben
350 positive rausgefischt in der zeit
die natürlich glaube ich damit gerechnet
haben dass sie positiv sind und wir
haben wir waren in baden württemberg das
erste der erste kreis der unter die 50
incidents von finike gekommen ist und
für mich war ausschlaggebend wenn wir
die 350 rausfinden bei 20.000 heißt es
die stecken schon mal niemanden mehr an
und das potenziert sich auch nicht
dagegen testen testen testen ein
argument für diese schnelltests
zerstreuter man hätte ja vor corona es
nicht für möglich gehalten dass ein
biologisches problem derartig hoch
politisch werden kann beschäftigt die
politik fast ausschließlich in den
letzten zwölf monaten
sie haben mal gesagt hört auf die
kanzlerin bei diesen
auseinandersetzungen zwischen dem
kanzleramt und den ministerpräsidenten
auch wenn vieles populär und populär ist
was sie verkündet sie sei ja besonnen
gewesen habe oft oder hätte auch oft
recht gehabt dieser ratschlag wird auf
die kanzlerin weiterhin ja der gilt
weiterhin und vor allen dingen gilt der
ratschlag sage ich mal eine menschen die
aus der kommunikationsbranche kommt
bleibt bei einer botschaft also ich
wünsche mir sehr sehr sehr sehr wird das
morgen endlich mal schluss ist mit
dieser kakophonie das also nach
stundenlangen ewigen beratung die
bundeskanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten der länder sich auf
irgendetwas einigen
und noch während sie das vorträgt in
stuttgart in schwerin oder in
irgendeinem ministerpräsidentin oder ein
präsident vor die kameras geht und dass
die vielleicht das gegenteil aber etwas
anderes erzählt das funktioniert nicht
und dann können sie als kommunikator
auch gleich aufhören
ob ihr wunsch dass es morgen eine abkehr
von der kakophonie geben wird in
erfüllung geht steht noch in den sternen
da müssen wir morgen abwarten ob
vielleicht sind die chance noch nicht so
hoch wie kessler hört auf die kanzlerin
dieser satz kenne ihn nicht so leicht
über die lippen aber sehenden auges die
dinge laufen zu lassen das kann ja auch
nicht aufgabe
verantwortliche politik sein naja ich
glaube das sind es nicht die richtigen
und tiefen die sie repräsentieren das
geht ja nicht darum sehenden auges alles
laufen zu lassen sondern es geht darum
diesen verheerenden eindruck den wir in
den letzten monaten bekommen haben zu
korrigieren
dieser verheerende eindruck der besagt
dass deutschland ein land ist indem
mangelndes können auf fehlendes wollen
trifft und das ist leider sehr
verheerend also wir sind hinten dran was
die impfquote angeht wir sind hinten
dran was die datenerfassung geht wir
werden vermutlich morgen wieder hören
dass irgendwann gesagt nimmerleinstag
sommers in allen gesundheitsämtern
eingeführt werden sollen da melden sich
alle wieder machen wir nicht und wir
brauchen vor allen dingen eine
gesamtbetrachtung einer
gesamtbetrachtung und ich würde also
raten dringend da nicht auf die
kanzlerin zu hören wo sie sagt unser
heil liegt in incidents werden 35 50
sind in stein gemeißelt wir müssen von
dieser monokausalen betrachtung dieser
fixierung auf die inzidenz werte weg wir
haben sonst die gefahr dass wir am ende
sagen werden lockdown gelungen republik
tot
da sind uns noch einen kleinen moment
bei der öffentlichkeit und auch bei den
kommunikationen zu fragen die auch
morgen wieder eine große rolle spielen
noch verweilen
jetzt ist er da schon offenbar einiges
durchgestochen worden also man liest in
den
nachrichten apps großen medienhäuser es
könnte wieder auf mehr persönliche
kontakte hinaus laufen also fünf oder
zehn aus mehreren haushalten dort wo
noch nicht geöffnet bücherläden
blumenläden gartencenter auf
möglicherweise mindestens einmal in der
woche ein test der nicht viel kostet und
wenn dass ich alles bewährt dann der
restliche einzelhandel und dann noch
gastronomie und kultur so im abstand von
zwei wochen wenn das jetzt schon so
rauskommt vor dieser diskussion nach der
wohl zitiert aus einem entwurf ich
glaube das ist der entwurf des
kanzleramt es was ich jetzt da gerade
gesagt habe tue das einer diskussion
morgen einer ergebnisorientierten
diskussion um die situation in
deutschland zu verbessern gut wenn das
jetzt schon auf dem markt ist ja der
eine sagt so der andere so ich finde es
jetzt in diesem fall nicht ganz so
schlimm weil dieses papier eben nicht
nur ein papier des kanzleramtes ist das
ist ein papier was die bundeskanzlerin
zusammen mit herrn müller und herrn
söder entwickelt hat das heißt da sind
schon länder mit dabei zwei jedenfalls
also insofern ist da sage ich mal ein
bisschen weniger krawall faktor drin
also vorher war ja wo sozusagen das
kanzleramt einfach mal aufgeschrieben
hat wie sie sich das gerne wünschen und
dann am nächsten tag mit den ländern
darüber endlos diskutiert haben
insofern bin ich da ganz hoffnungsfroh
was mich allerdings ich habe das auch
gelesen was mich da ein bisschen
entsetzt ist dass wir jetzt offenbar
schon wieder den fehler machen wollen
wie zur weihnachtszeit dass man also
irgendwie ein christliches fest wie eine
monstranz vor sich her trägt und man
jetzt also sozusagen vor ostern wieder
große familien begegnungen erlauben will
und ich muss sagen das hat mich schon
weihnachten wahnsinnig gemacht da konnte
man noch sagen mein gott das war ein
total blödes jahr
und dann haben wir eben auch mal ein
blödes weihnachtsfest warum sollen wir
jetzt nicht auch noch einmal ein blödes
osterfest haben ja also das halten wir
auch noch aus dass wir dann vielleicht
nur mit einem oder zwei leuten
verbringen und nicht mit leuten aus zwei
haushalten die dann noch was wir alles
zu tode regulieren die dann auch noch
eine unbegrenzte anzahl von kindern
unter 14 mitbringen können also
wenn sie das dann sich in der großen
familie vorstellen haben sie dann doch
das heißt also dass diese diskussion da
wieder aufkommt er soll ja an ostern
auch noch weiter gelockert werden gerade
kritisiert haben von alexander kissler
was diesen politischen workflow angeht
dass dieses zu reden dieses diskutieren
schon vorab dieses auch vielleicht
verwirren auch der öffentlichkeit durch
unterschiedliche stellungnahmen die
morgen möglicherweise eine geringe
halbwertszeit haben tut das der sache
gut
nein das tut der sache überhaupt nicht
gut die sachen werden ja soweit ich das
mitgekriegt immer vom kanzleramt
durchgestochen das heißt man bekommt in
dem fall ist es abgeschwächt etwas
anders aber wenn man kommt oft die
maximale position des kanzleramts
präsentiert und nach kann das kanzleramt
und die kanzlerin sich zurücklehnen und
sagen na gut wir haben es leider
abbrechen müssen hätten wir uns an die
strengen vorgaben die ich gehabt hatte
mit herrn brauchen gehalten wäre es
schlechter gekommen wir haben auch jetzt
schon das problem dass einige
ministerpräsident herrn günther aus
schleswig-holstein beispielsweise sich
von dem jetzt vorliegenden papier
absetzen das heißt es entwickelt am
anfang so starke fliehkräfte dass sehr
sehr schwierig ist dann zu einem
gemeinsamen nenner zu kommen und diese
treffen alle zwei wochen sind wirklich
absurdes theater man streitet wie die
kesselflicker für 30 minuten auf der
pressekonferenz
einigkeit simuliert und danach geht
parallel ich wieder das pflücken weiter
kommunikation braucht verlässlichkeit
und klugheit und das ist nicht
verlässlich und unklug einspruch an
einer stelle
diese papiere werden mit sicherheit
nicht vom kanzleramt sein doch in
sondern sie werden in dem moment bekannt
wo das in 16 staatskanzleien geht das
war eine längere meinen sie haben werden
dass wir morgen sehen was dann übrig
bleibt das wäre ja morgen haben ja noch
nichts runde noch besprechen
herr professor lehr ein aspekt bei der
frage wie man corona auf lange sicht
überwinden das q2 virus samt mutation in
die ecke quetschen kann ist ja das
impfen das ist ja ein wechsel auf die
zukunft zu sagen wenn das mit ihm voran
geht dann werden wir irgendwann mal
dieses virus und diese mit 19 erkrankung
beherrschen
sehen sie da optimistisch in die zukunft
was die letzten monate die nächsten
monate angehen wir sind einem
hochpolitischen jahr ist bundestagswahl
und wie gesagt erst eine durchimpfung im
höheren prozentbereich führte dazu dass
wir möglicherweise an wirklich lockern
können
ganz genau so empfinde es auf jeden fall
einige schlüssel dazu dass wir aus
dieser pandemie eine lockerung übergehen
können
sie haben es gesagt letztendlich wir
brauchen eine deutlich höhere quote
momentan liegen wir wirklich bei dieser
ströhen 45 wenn sie das vergleichen und
großbritannien habe ungefähr 30 prozent
also deutlich hinten dran
wir bräuchten also nach meinung nach
unseren berechnungen brauchen sie
ungefähr 20 bis 25 prozent wurde damit
sie überhaupt erst mal irgendwas sehen
was die inzidenz angeht und auch im
größeren maßstab was vielleicht
hospitalisierung und er ließ angeht also
wohl wir jetzt natürlich schon viele
altenheime geben stamm fehlen uns ja
immer noch 95 prozent der bevölkerung
und wenn die geschwindigkeit sich so
beibehält dann wird das noch relativ
lange dauern also das heißt wir müssen
wir dringend nachlegen und auch hier ist
ein großes kommunikations desaster was
beispiel sollte den astra zeneca
wirkstoff lange dass auch hier gilt es
jetzt wirklich mal einheitlich eine
saubere kommunikationslinie zu fahren
glauben sie denn dass astrazeneca dieser
wirkstoffe sagen kommunikationsdesaster
dass er zu unrecht sozusagen als
minderwertig dargestellt wird obwohl er
das gar nicht ist dass die politik da
noch mal klar sich erklären muss dass
der auch eben verimpft werden kann weil
er offenbar so zwischen 500.000 und
einer million impfdosen im schrank vor
sich hin oder her wenn es genau was ich
mir weniger fahrzeug apotheker und habe
auch lange in der pharmaindustrie
gearbeitet und glaube ich das
einschätzen zu können
das ist ein qualitativ hoch wirksamer
impfstoff der wirklich sehr gute
wirksamkeit hat und ich sage nur die
wirksamkeit die beschrieben wird bezieht
sich vor allem auf schwerwiegende
symptome das heißt also solche dinge wie
haben ja haben beschwerden
schluckbeschwerden
protest und ähnliches die vielleicht
nicht verhindert werden können aber
krankenhauseinweisungen wenn verhindert
vor allem auch bei den über 80-jährigen
und vor allem auch die todesfälle
verhindert und es ist ja genau das was
wir eigentlich wollten
ob es sonst jetzt mit einer infektion
nach dem astra zeneca impfstoff
vielleicht ein bisschen schlechter geht
ich glaube damit kann man relativ gut
leben und die betonung darauf dass man
damit leben leben kann und nicht
verstärkt und ich glaube das ist das
ganz wichtigen und sie haben gesagt es
liegt eine million impfdosen liegen um
das reicht noch lange nicht aus für das
was wir haben das ist ungefähr ein
prozent vielleicht der bevölkerung nach
aber es ist eine sehr gute wirkstoff von
eben auch in den über 80-jährigen
wirksam
ich hoffe sehr dass die ständige
impfkommission dort auch dann bald die
empfehlung verändern wird
dank ihnen scheint ja tübingen so etwas
wie die insel der seligen zu sein sie
haben gesagt 20.000 schnelltests haben
sie dadurch gefäß durch geführt da
können manche städte gleicher
größenordnung und auch landkreise nur
von träumen das ist ja auch eines der
punkte die wichtig sind
lockerungen zu rechtfertigen und
tatsächlich auch durchzuhalten
damit man sie nicht wieder zurücknehmen
muss was er dann besonders problematisch
wird aber haben wir überhaupt die
kapazitäten die produktionskapazitäten
die test kapazitäten um das wirklich
flächendeckend in deutschland nicht nur
in tübingen zu machen der
bundesgesundheitsminister musste da ja
mal wieder zurückrudern und sagen die
ankündigung zum am ersten märz geht das
vielleicht entdeckt in der
bundesrepublik offenbar geht es doch
nicht so schnell ist das überhaupt
realistisch in nächster zeit ausweichend
zu testen
also ich glaube es ist realistisch ich
habe kontakte auch zu einem
geschäftsführung von einer großen sehr
großen firma der hat mir zugesagt 20
millionen innerhalb von vier wochen für
baden württemberg liefern zu können an
schnelltest sie dürfen eins nicht
vergessen es sollte nicht jeder getestet
wir haben jetzt unsere erfahrung gemacht
mit unserer teststation die ganze zeit
schon also mit diesem mobilen test
praxis es einer der zu hause im home
office ist und einmal die woche
einkaufen geht mit fb2 maske der muss
nicht zweimal oder dreimal die woche zum
testen kommen das unsinn
aber beispielsweise habe ich letzte
woche 40 fahrschullehrer eingelangt weil
bei denen es besonders wichtig dass sie
sich regelmäßig testen lassen und die
fahrschule auch weil die können im auto
nicht abstandsregel von 1,5 metern
halten und sind eine stunde zusammen in
so einem auto sie brauchen aber die
fahrlehrer weil wenn wir die leute nicht
ausbilden und die keinen führerschein
kriegen dann fehlen polizisten dann
fehlen rettungsassistenten und dann
fehlen viele berufe die einfach nicht
weitermachen können dh wir brauchen noch
ein gewisses system und eine test
strategie und ich bin ganz ruhig war ja
bei der bundespressekonferenz von
minister sparen eingeladen
ich habe jetzt auch schon so ein paar
sachen davon im voraus mitbekommen
ich glaube dass da einiges übernommen
wird von dem was wir da vorgeschlagen
haben und was wir in tübingen schon
praktiziert haben und die kommunen
werden jetzt mit eingebunden und wir
sind in tübingen kann gallisches dorf
das ist ein irrtum ich bin mindestens
von 25 städten in baden württemberg
angeschrieben worden habe die auch ein
gelernt habe so die auch test besorgt
aber nicht nur baden württemberg bayern
auch hessen also die kommunen sind da
längst schon viel viel aktiver wie die
politik denkt also da läuft viel viel
mehr auf kommunaler ebene wie wir uns
das ausschreiben und es ist auf jede
stadt umsetzbaren das behaupte ich jetzt
einfach mal weil ich ja gesehen habe gut
wenn es jetzt um diesen im pfund
testerfolg letztendlich geht da gab es
ja ankündigungen beim impfen zunächst
das wird nicht so gut geklappt
beim testen hat man jetzt
sicherheitshalber und rückzieher gemacht
von diesem erfolg des impfen und das
testen hängt natürlich auch die
nachhaltigkeit der lockerungen ab wie
klug oder unglück hat die politik da
agiert und wie agiert sie gerade im
moment damit denn das ist ja wie gesagt
das a und o des erfolgs im kampf gegen
brunner ja wenn er ständig den satz
impfen rettet leben keine
pressekonferenz von frau merkel wurde
dieser satz so oder ähnlich nicht fällt
und dann schauen wir uns an wie viel
verimpft wird wir sind ungefähr bei fünf
prozent der bevölkerung das ist richtig
und am wochenende gilt offenbar dass das
alte beamten mutter hoch freitags nach
das macht jeder seins weil offenbar
samstag und sonntag kaum etwas verändert
wird da gibt es immer ein wochenend
knick das natürlich desaströse wenn ich
sage impfen rettet leben dann heißt ja
im prinzip wochenende red mir mal lieber
nicht so leben
bei den tests das gleiche am ersten märz
sollten kostenlose tests eingeführt
werden da wohl daher sparen
zurückgepfiffen
jetzt ist die rede vom bürger testen
zweimal die woche
also man weiß auch noch nicht genau ob
es einen schnelltest durch fachpersonal
betrifft oder selbst system man selber
machen kann
wir bewegen uns also auf einen
politischen wie kommunikativen gau
erster klasse zu einerseits haben wir
eine ankündigung rhetorischen immer
schriller wird wir haben ein moral
regiment das immer autoritärer
daherkommt und wir haben immer weiter
dahinter zurückbleibende einlöse
verfahren von diesen vielen versprechen
als auch versprechens niveau wird immer
höher
dass ein lösungs sie wohl geringer weil
man eben aufs versprechen immer noch
eins drauf satteln und das ist sehr sehr
problematisch und ich fürchte dass das
mittelfristig zu einer entfremdung von
der demokratie vielleicht nicht aber von
den tragenden kräfte unserer republik
schon führen könnte wenn das stichwort
jetzt politischer und kommunikative ist
er ja frau federle bitte wenn sie ich
glaube wir müssen einfach mal
pragmatischer handeln das ist unser
problem ja wir stehen uns selber im weg
wir sind irgendwie wir deutschen sind zu
gründlich in manchen dingen ja wir
bewegen alles x-mal kontrollieren es
noch zehn mal schreiben es dann aus wir
lassen es dann noch mal prüfen ob es
überhaupt so schon geprüft ist und haben
dann noch irgendwelche rechtlichen
bedenken
und das ist in der krise vollkommen
falsch in der krise muss es umgekehrt
sein ich muss einigermaßen republik
haben muss was ausprobieren muss man
pragmatisch handeln und dann kann ich
immer noch kontrollieren ob das
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
nachjustiert werden kann oder anders
gemacht werden kann
und ich glaube das ist ein großes
problem und das ist auch das was die
bevölkerung und anlastet ja oder den den
politiker man laster der dass sie sagen
da gibt es keine klare linie in der eine
kommt mit dem der andere kommt mit dem
dann kommen 1000 bedenken und bis dann
endlich was eingeführt wird ist es
eigentlich schon wieder fasten schritt
zu spät also das war mir menschen so das
ist mit dem testen so das ist mit den
ganz
ich kann ihnen sagen ich habe ihm früher
anfangen symptomlos zu testen
in altersheim da hab ich zu hören
gekriegt dann können sie ja vom
sozialgericht die kosten einen klagen
es ist nicht vorgesehen ja und das dabei
war es klar wenn man nach italien
geschaut hat dass wir das tun müssen
genau so ging es mit dem schnelltest
dann habe ich halt gesagt gut wenn die
nicht bezahlt man mache ich halt eine
spendenaktion
aber das ist das was die bevölkerung der
politik gerade glaube ich oder warum die
bevölkerung vor der politik inzwischen
doch größte bedenken hat und unsicher
ist weil da einfach keine klare
strategie dahinter steckt und es einfach
immer ewig dauert also sind jetzt
ankündigungs fragen die das funktioniert
oft nicht so alexander kissler hat
gerade gesagt politischer und
kommunikativer gau da könnte man noch
eins draufsetzen wenn man jetzt locker
streite und man merkt plötzlich die
infektionszahlen die inzidenz zahlen der
erfährt also wie viel jemand andere
anstecken kann schießt wieder durch die
decke man muss das alles rückabwickeln
in einen harten lockdown was passiert da
eigentlich in der politik die
bevölkerung drängt darauf dass gelockert
wird dann wird gelockert dann wird das
alles wieder zurückgezogen was bedeutet
das eigentlich auch für die
innenpolitische situation in deutschland
na ja also ich würde mal aus meiner
erfahrung heraus sagen dass die politik
ja auch nicht besonders mutig ist ja ich
meine wir haben ein war ja und ein
politiker muss ja auch gefallen so als
würde ich wieder gewählt also das
verkompliziert die ganze sache in diesem
jahr ein bisschen ja also speziell in
baden-württemberg zum beispiel oder in
rheinland pfalz und man muss aber ja
auch mal die verantwortlichkeiten klar
stellen ja also eine große zeitung mit
vier buchstaben hat ja seit weihnachten
auch der bundeskanzlerin rum also in die
bundeskanzlerin persönlich alle leute in
deutschland um bringt ja das ist
überhaupt nicht ihren job
die die die gesundheitsvorsorge ist
ländersache und sie ist vor allen dingen
sache der kommunen und der landkreise et
cetera und ich kann meine frau fehler da
ist auch wirklich das aller beste
beispiel dafür
wie die jemand verantwortung übernimmt
ja das würde ich mir von jedem
bürgermeister wünschen in köln in
flensburg tut das ja in düsseldorf ja
aber der bürgermeister in düsseldorf der
denkt sich dann eine verbotszone aus
also in dem in den kreisen bewegen wir
uns und da muss ich mal sagen und frau
federle hat das ja hingekriegt obwohl er
angeblich die bundeskanzlerin total
versagt hat ja so also das heißt sie hat
ja ein erfolg der sozusagen von unten
kommt jan nämlich schon vor ort und die
probleme alles wird vor ort geregelt und
und sie können natürlich sagen ja
letztlich ist immer die bundeskanzlerin
verantwortlich aber ehrlich gesagt
können sie von der bundeskanzlerin auch
nicht erwarten dass die sich jetzt mit
dem letzten schnell test in tübingen und
in cannstatt auseinandersetzt und das
heißt es werden richtung vorgegeben so
und dann sind wir wieder da wo wir
vorhin waren das die ministerpräsidenten
als länderchefs die die ware
verantwortung haben weiche knie bekommen
ja die haben dann angst die halten
keinen druck aus und da muss man halt
auch mal unangenehme wahrheiten
verbreiten und man muss natürlich die
die kanzlerin also ich würde jetzt nicht
so von der verantwortung entlassen eine
kanzlerin wie frau merkel die von anfang
an den eindruck erweckt hat und ihn auch
erzeugen wollte es ist chef oder chefin
sache die muss sich dann auch alles
gefallen lassen wenn es nicht
funktioniert für die ausbleibenden oder
für die negativen folgen ihres nicht
handeln zur verantwortung gezogen zu
werden also man kann es nicht sagen
sie macht gerne die pressekonferenzen
gibt regierungserklärungen ab und wenn
sich läuft sind die länder schon schuld
das ist ein kompliziertes föderales
system ist da bin ich ja völlig bei
ihnen aber für merkel ist schon die frau
an der spitze die gesamt linie vorgibt
und die auch einen großen ärgers hat
selber als solche wahrgenommen zu werden
also da muss ich widersprechen
wird ja auch immer also wir müssen schon
ein bisschen aufpassen dass wir mit
unserer sprache auch so anrichten 2 geht
gar nicht es wird ja auch gerne von
herrn kubicki und anderen menschen
die rechtmäßigkeit dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
angezweifelt ja so die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gibt es
seit bestehen der bundesrepublik so und
es ist ja nichts anderes als der versuch
als der versuch einen sack flöhe zu
koordinieren ja also das heißt die
bundeskanzlerin ist nicht die chefin der
ministerpräsidenten sondern die
bundeskanzlerin
sag mal in ihrer ganzen verzweiflung
bietet sozusagen bei vollem
körpereinsatz an diese völlig
widerstrebenden länderchefs irgendwie
auf eine linie zu bringen ja und das
heißt und wo auch was wir morgen wieder
hören das ist ja jetzt immer der
kleinste gemeinsame nenner
natürlich auch viel mit mit politischer
verantwortung dann zu tun der 17 also 16
länder chefinnen und chefs und die
bundeskanzlerin die sich ja auch auf
zahlen stützen die zum beispiel der
coffee cellular von professor lehr
sozusagen erzeugt die pandemie hat ja
einen vorteil auch nicht fachleute
wissen was kompliziert klingende
fachbegriffe zu bedeuten haben zum
beispiel das wort incidents das wusste
vor corona kaum jemand außer denjenigen
die sich mit instanzen beschäftigen
jetzt weiß es jeder 35 50 oder doch 10
oder sind 100 auch noch ausreichend
können sie uns noch mal sagen der
inzidenz wert über den es wieder
diskutiert 35 ist die magische grenze
soll jetzt möglicherweise doch wieder
auf 50 erhöht werden andere sagen
zwischen 1500 ist auch okay ich glaube
sie sagen ihr müsst euch bei 10 liegen
um wirklich zu lockern
wo macht der inzidenz wert oder diese
frage wie viele menschen pro 100.000
einwohner in sieben tagen inspiziert
werden wo machte er sinn und wo macht er
keinen sinn
ich glaube der ist vor allem dann sinn
wenn es darum geht können wir die
infektion eigentlich noch nachverfolgen
solange ich jetzt keine schnelltests hat
und wie vor wird schon noch angedeutet
so was wie sommers könne nach
bevölkerung nicht existent ist und ich
beispielsweise eben auch wie die
übermittlung von den gesundheitsämtern
über das faxgerät und ähnlich jetzt habe
so lange habe ich natürlich ein problem
und das heißt dass präsident für mich
natürlich eine große rolle weil er
bedeutet eine hohe inzidenz bedeutet
eine hohe belastung der gesundheitsämter
und damit eine schlechte
nachverfolgbarkeit prinzipiell sehen sie
ja momentan das mit der inzidenz die wir
haben wir eigentlich mit den
krankenhäusern ganz gut klar kommen das
ist ja immer auch so ein korrelat damit
einher geht das heißt ich hab nur
inzidenz damit habe ich natürlich dann
auch eine hohe auslastung auf den
kranken den krankenhäusern
das ist richtig und das müssen wir
natürlich auch mit berücksichtigen und
ist auch wichtig dass man solche
parameter mit bedenken aber was wär halt
einfach auch bedingt müssen zum einen
haben wir bei einer hohen incidents eben
auch in ruhe virus last und damit auch
eine hohe wahrscheinlichkeit dass
mutationen oder modernen auftreten
die möglicherweise dann halt auch
vielleicht wieder infektiöse sind oder
eben auch nicht mehr reagieren auf die
impfung das ist natürlich der eine punkt
und der zweite punkt den wir auch nicht
vergessen leuten ist dass wir natürlich
auch noch so was die post kurbelt haben
oder long kobelt je nachdem wie sie das
nennen wollen spätfolgen
die natürlich auch auftreten vor allem
auch bei asymptomatischen teilweise auch
bei kindern leute die quasi überhaupt
keine schwere infektion durch aufnahmen
weil ein teilweise noch monatelang nach
und das sind wirklich teilweise bis zu
40 prozent der kogit patienten und das
dürfen wir auch einfach nicht vergessen
dass das natürlich auch eine rolle
spielt in dieser ganzen betrachtung für
mich ist es jetzt letztendlich auch
nicht so dass der wert wirklich bei 10
oder niedriger als zehn liegen sollte
wir sehen unseren analysen einfach das
in der zweiten welle eigentlich ab einer
inzidenz von ungefähr 20 plötzlich das
system so umgekipptes da sehen sie dass
die inzidenz und plötzlich durch die
decke geschossen sondern das heißt das
ab dann eigentlich die gesundheitsämter
nicht hinterherkam jetzt hat mir
natürlich mit dem instrument der testung
auch noch ein ganz neue optionen frau
federer hat das ganz schön gesagt und
ich finde das ist ein ganz wichtiges
instrument das wir jetzt auch mit
bedenken müssen dass wir damit natürlich
auch einfach leute identifizieren können
die automatische außen rum laufen das
ist ja eine der gemeinheiten dieser
infektion dass das symptomatisch sind
bei einem stücken oder bei einer
klassischen erkältung der erkennen sich
in relativ schnell
jetzt wissen sie es halt einfach nicht
fest ist und deswegen müssen wir dieses
instrument einfach mit dazu nehmen
aber was mir halt auch einfach fehlt ist
eine evaluation der maßnahmen es wird
vieles einfach so in den raum geworfen
wie dünger aus gras oder aufs bett
geschmissen und man hofft dass etwas
wächst um das funktioniert und vieles
funktioniert halt nicht also viele der
maßnahmen wenn einfach mal gemacht und
dann schaut man was rauskommt und ich
glaube da müssen ort liegen wie frau
federle das in tübingen gemacht hat es
glaube ich genau richtig dass wir
einfach mal schauen wie viele
schnelltests anbietet positive haben wir
ihn brauchen wir das eigentlich und wie
sie dann sagen auch einfach noch einmal
nachjustieren damit wir dann einfach
auch sinnvoll die ressourcen einsetzen
erklärt wir haben gesagt bei 20 incident
20 ist eine nachverfolgung schon fast
nicht mehr möglich lange zeit wurde ja
die inzidenz 50 wie eine monstranz
vorangetragen nach dem motto ab dann
können die gesundheitsämter nicht mehr
nachzufolgen eine frage kann man da
gesundheitsämter wirklich mit incidents
werten vergleichen da gibt es
gesundheitsämter mit unterschiedlicher
personeller ausstattung möglicherweise
mit unterschiedlicher personeller
qualifikation seine frage ob ich in
einen hotspot einer gesundheitsamt habe
oder in einer gegend wo es wenig fälle
gibt ist das mit einer solchen mit einer
solchen zahlenwerte 20 oder 50 überhaupt
sinnvoll machbar und dann auch politisch
begründbaren also dieser wert von 50
reihe sicherlich ihren politisch
gemachte der eigentlich zum scheitern
verurteilt war das haben alle immer
gesagt der wert von 50 ist in der ersten
welle der pandemie eigentlich nicht
einmal erreicht worden und trotzdem
wurde das neue werk von der lockerung
hergenommen und jeder experte hat gesagt
dass er zu hoch ist wie sie sagen
natürlich hängt bis zum schluss vom
gesundheitsamt ab wie gut das geschulte
so gut dass ausgestattet ist über welche
ressourcen verfügt ich glaube
man kann es letztendlich nicht für jedes
amt individuell diese schwelle
festmachen aber ich glaube man sieht
schon dass dieser wert von 50 definitiv
zu hoch ist und das einfach niedriger
sein sollte
aber wir sehen halt im moment einfach
auch dass wir eben mit der mutante und
auch dem ja der unlust der bevölkerung
einfach diesen wert nicht mehr erreichen
können und da kann man jetzt natürlich
zum einen über legen halte ich an den
wert fest oder überlege ich mir eben
auch neue maßnahmen wie zum beispiel
jetzt die schnelltests einsetzen kann
und vielleicht auch andere
nachverfolgung wieder ein bisschen
geschickter mache andere nachverfolgen
stichwort vor federle schnelltest das
was sie anbieten ist das eine jetzt
sollen auch setzt tests sind stehen vor
der zulassung die ist glaube ich sogar
schon erteilt wird in den nächsten tagen
möglicherweise auch in den
drogeriemärkten und den apotheken zu
kaufen sein also man testet sich dann
selbst im vorderen rachen oder
nasenbereich damit man mit dem
wattestäbchen nicht so weit rein muss
aber ist das wirklich so sinnvoll wenn
jeder selbst dann sich testet ist das
ergebnis dass dabei rauskommt nicht die
frage bin ich positiv bin ich negativ
dann wirklich so belastbar
also die studien sagen dass es sehr
identisch ist also von geschultem
personal oder medizinischen personal
wenn man das vergleicht mit laien die
das selber bei sich durchgeführt haben
gibt es da wenig unterschiede
das ist ganz gut es hat sich gezeigt
allerdings und das sehe ich als großes
problem wir müssen noch mehr aufklären
müssen den menschen noch sagen was ist
denn wenn ich zu hause nicht este und
ich bin es symptomatisch und stellt fest
jetzt bin ich positiv ich rechne ja gar
nicht damit
wir haben die erfahrung gemacht und wir
machen das ja wie gesagt jetzt seit
mehreren monaten dass manche vollkommen
geschockt waren und die anderen wieder
haben gesagt das kann gar nicht sein das
ist unmöglich ich bin ja hierher noch
gekommen weil ich eigentlich die
bestätigung wollte dass ich negativ bin
das heißt ich muss auch eine gewisse
verantwortung den menschen übertragen
darüber muss ich sie dann aber aufklären
wie sie damit umgehen b was sie dann
machen müssen
deswegen bin ich der meinung dass wir
erst mal diese zentren komplett anlaufen
lassen die ja in baden württemberg schon
relativ gut sind obwohl das
sozialministerium sich da wirklich auch
bis zum schluss gefunden hat und die das
dann einfach in eigeninitiative auf
nachfragen bei mir gemacht haben aber
ich glaube wir sollten uns erstmal auf
solche strukturen konzentrieren und dann
parallel dazu eine totale aufklärung
betreiben wie die menschen mit umgehen
wenn sie sich selbst testen was sie
machen müssen weil wir müssen das auch
klären kann ich mir selber attest
ausstellen
wie läuft es und wir sollten uns
vielleicht auch überlegen ob noch andere
mittel haben wie zb mit luca mit der app
das sind sachen die wir zumindest mal
denken müssen ja weil nur testen allein
und zuhause im kämmerlein
das ist so einfach aber frau federle
digitale nachverfolgung wird bei
menschen die über 60 oder 70 jahre alt
sind sozusagen mit eigener initiative
auf einer app schwierig werden müssen
wir das nicht auch im analogen bereich
noch verstärken denn viele menschen
können mit einer app nichts anfangen ich
glaube wir müssen alles machen alle
mittel die wir haben müssen wird zur
verfügung und nehmen wir haben keine
andere chance was sollen wir denn tun
also wir wissen ja gar nicht ganz genau
ob sich irgendwann vielleicht noch
mutanten entwickeln die bei der impfung
gar nicht mehr wirklich 100 prozent
wirken also die wo die wo wir keinen
schutz haben wir wissen nicht wie lange
die impfung ausreicht wie lange werden
schutz haben und ich glaube ein sollten
wir nicht machen was ich oft auch im
sommer den eindruck hatte dass jeder
irgendwie so ein bisschen gehofft hat
auch das thema erledigt sich von alleine
ich glaube was wirklich aus dieser krise
mitnehmen müssen ist dass wir sagen wir
sind vorbereitet und vorbereitet
bedeutet für mich dass wir auch
vorbereitet sind sollten jetzt doch
irgendwelche mutanten auftreten die
vielleicht nicht so einfach im griff zu
kriegen sind wir können wir können nicht
ständig die menschen nur einsperren oder
abschotten das ist das
natürlich ich bin ärztin ich will jedes
leben schützen aber ich sage ich krieg
auch ein langsames sterben mit jeweils
sie sterben auch psychisch die menschen
dass sie können kinder mich ein jahr
lang isolieren und gerade wenn sie aus
schwierigen eltern oder ein schwieriges
elternhaus haben sie können die die
wirtschaft nicht ständig knüppeln ja da
gibt es menschen und ich sehe dass ich
habe ja auch eine praxis die sind jetzt
depressiv die haben ihre ihren lebensmut
und alles verloren und die muss sich mit
einbeziehen das ist auch ein tod auf
raten
und insofern denke ich wir müssen aus
dieser situation lernen und jetzt alle
wirklich alle mittel überprüfen und ein
und alle mittel auch uns alle mittel
nutzen um zu sagen so wird es in zukunft
gemacht egal ob irgendwann das virus auf
eine gewisse art sich abschwächen oder
auch nicht gut das heißt es geht ja
nicht nur um das verhalten der bürger es
geht um die wahl das verhalten der ärzte
der theke des krankenhauspersonals es
geht auch natürlich um die reaktion der
politik die da immer auch eine rolle
spielt im guten wie im schlechten wenn
wir mal bei einer person bleiben die da
seit einem jahr auch einen ziemlich
guten lauf jedenfalls bisher hatte
nämlich sparen der
bundesgesundheitsminister der sich da
profilieren konnte da hat man ihn ja
schon ganz in der nähe des kanzleramtes
gesehen nach der bundestagswahl jetzt
ist heute eine umfrage veröffentlicht
worden dass 40 prozent der menschen mit
ihm unzufrieden sind hat er sich jetzt
speziell auf sparen bei dem das
krisen-management zusammenläuft der da
auch sicherlich mit der bundeskanzlerin
eng zusammenarbeiten muss es hängt viel
an den beiden hat er sich da überschätzt
in den letzten monaten ist er da auch
vielleicht getrieben worden von eigenen
ambitionen aber eben auch von der
ungeduld der bürger naja von eigenen
ambitionen vermutlich auch ist er
angetreten im team wie ein sack mit
herrn laschet wollten sie gewissermaßen
gemeinsame cdu-vorsitz haben und vor
einem halben jahr war noch der favorit
unter den kandidaten und sympathisch zu
ersparen und das ist ja der letzte ist
also von einer belastung für die partei
und das tor ist von einem
hoffnungsträger für die partei und
lang zu einem belastungs träger für
partei und land geworden er hat zu viel
versprochen zu viel falsche zahlen auch
versprochen mitte februar werden alle
bewohner von pflege- und altenheim
durchgeimpft werden dann die kostenlosen
tickets anfang märz zu den westfalen
nichts wissen
dann hieß es im januar schon es wird die
gesamte gegeben da warten wir immer noch
darauf vielleicht gibt es die morgen und
er hat sich auch leider gottes
verheddert in der in einer rhetorik die
ich also für für sehr gefährlich halte
nämlich immer wenn er nach seiner
eigenen verantwortung gefragt worden ist
hat er sofort die verantwortung von sich
geschoben gesagt wir alle müssen
miteinander aus dieser krise
herauskommen wir alle machen fehler
wir müssen miteinander an dieser
bewährungsprobe wachsen und dadurch
hatte natürlich wenn er das immer
wiederholt und hat es immer wieder holt
den eindruck vermittelt vermittelt ich
bemühe mich zwar aber wenn fehler
passieren sind wir alle schuld also auch
die bürger müssen mitmachen und hat
deshalb zu leicht in den schwarzen peter
für schlechtes management an den bürger
weiter gegeben der sich eben nicht in
der von den regierenden vorgesehenen
weise diszipliniert verhalten das ist
glaube ich seien ein großes problem
andererseits faktisch ist er auch
gescheitert an föderalen
zuständigkeitswirrwarr das muss man auch
sagen natürlich kann er nicht
durchregieren bis zu den landratsämtern
und die ministerpräsidenten
aber dieses nassforsche auftreten als
topmanager fällt ihnen natürlich in dem
moment auf die füße wo er als schlechter
manager sich offenbart und das ist
momentan der fall
krisenkommunikation gibt es ja nicht nur
im zusammenhang mit pandemien bekämpfung
sondern in dem fall jetzt eben auch in
eigener sache
was hat er falsch gemacht was hätte er
anders machen können oder gegen das gar
nicht anders weil es gibt ja auch keine
blaupause für ein verhalten wie man
jetzt hier als bundesgesundheitsminister
vorgeht alten beamten will sven nichts
macht macht auch nichts verkehrt und das
macht er sparen eben nicht so und er hat
sich halt aus der deckung heraus gewagt
er hat sich
er ist auch zuständig im übrigen das
heißt er kriegt natürlich auch am
meisten ab und ich glaube die
zustimmungswerte zu ihren schwan die
gehen parallel zu den ermüdungen kurven
ja also ich meine wir alle sind genervt
wir alle haben die nase voll von diesem
virus und wir alle wollen auch mal
wieder in die kneipe gehen und mal in
urlaub fahren etwas machen so wir sind
alle frustriert und dieser ganze frust
der lässt sich natürlich auch an ihm hat
auch manchmal ein bisschen pech kommt
dann noch hinzu aber ich würde nie sagen
dass den spanier sind großer versager
wäre oder so das ist einfach ungerecht
da habe ich meine ich glaube das haben
die leute auch die wissen dass auch also
weder frau merkel noch herrscht noch
frau von der leyen decken den ganzen tag
darüber nach wie sie uns quälen können
sondern die bemühen sich zu helfen ja
und das gelingt mal und mal gelingt es
nicht ja und ersparen ist es halt so er
steht einfach total im feuer
aber wenn jetzt die krisenkommunikation
doch ein problem ist oder besser klavier
ein kleiner moment vertreter der die die
krisen wie müsste die
krisenkommunikation jetzt an dieser
stelle aussehen
an diesem quasi an diesen möglicherweise
an dieser weggabelung was passiert jetzt
locker und weiter lockerung das ist ja
jetzt in die entscheidende
möglicherweise entscheidende tage
das ist ja mein lieblingsthema also jede
ehrliche kommunikation scheitert
natürlich dann wenn sie keine botschaft
haben ja da können sie nicht
kommunizieren ja und wenn die wenn die
morgen abend uns da irgendwas verkünden
und dann gleich wieder drei
ministerpräsidenten
was anderes sagen da brauchen sie nicht
zu kommunizieren
das brauchen sich nur verdattert
anzugucken und dann stehen sie da vor
ich würde mir klare botschaften wünschen
und klare botschaften setzen auch klare
beschlüsse voraus also ich würde mir zum
beispiel für morgen jetzt unabhängig von
allen
überlegung was öffnen könnte eventuell
das sind ja alles das sind ja lauter
variablen die wir alle nicht kennen ja
aber eins können sie zum beispiel
beschließen die können morgen
beschließen dass dieser ganze
astrazeneca impfstoff der darum nicht
weil leute das nicht wollen klammer auch
das war auch ein presse versagen ja also
der celica ist von presse runter gemacht
worden weil einfach einfach einige
journalisten nicht wissenschaftliche
veröffentlichungen lesen konnten egal
es gibt ein akzeptanzproblem es gibt
aber auch viele leute ich gerne hätten
und ich würde mir wünschen dass sie
morgen beschließen wer auch immer afrika
im stoff haben möchte der kriegt völlig
unabhängig vom alter weil und da komme
ich zurück auf was der herr professor
lehr gesagt hatte wir haben doch nicht
so viele möglichkeiten die einzige
möglichkeit ist kontakte zu vermeiden
und impfen impfen impfen und es ist doch
völlig wurscht ob wir einen 30-jährigen
impfen oder 1 60 jährigen ist es wieder
einer weniger der andere leute ansteckt
der dieser der selber krank wird
darunter diese eine frage vielleicht an
herrn leer noch zudem wenn der professor
lehr ist es diese priorisierung die wir
beim impfen haben ist die ist die nicht
mehr machbar sollte man das ändern auch
in bezug auf astra zeneca wenn
muss die impfstrategie geändert werden
da ich denke aus der jetzigen situation
ist die im strategie auf jeden fall ich
finde sie ändern änderbar aus wenn man
sich anschaut wie sie ähnlich entwickelt
wurde dann wurde sie das humanitäre
sicher interessen entwickelt dass wir
zuerst mal die wohlhabenden gruppen
schützen
das ist auch richtig so außerdem fiktion
logischer sicht wesentlich weniger
erstmal die mittelalten und die jungen
zu impfen weil das sind tatsächlich die
die vor allem die panini treiben und
dann mit hohen sie denn es werden auch
in die altersheime reinfahren haben das
ist natürlich eine problematik von daher
denke ich aber auch dass wir dieselbe
strategie ist wieder deutsch kompliziert
ein bisschen gemacht haben dass wir
einfach zu viele regularien drin haben
zu wenig flexibilität und ich glaube es
davon kann nicht sein dass eben diese
impfstoffe herumliegt und das wäre so
unflexibel vorgehen ich glaube wir
brauchen auf jeden fall eine änderung
der strategie profit alles also ich sehe
das auch so ich meinen dass der
impfstoff freigegeben wird für über
65-jährige liegt ja im moment bei der
stiko ich im moment sind es nicht dass
sie meist ein bisschen tigers endlich
genehmigt genau ich muss hier gerade
ganz schlecht wie auf jeden fall
irgendwie ich kann mich darüber nicht
hinweg setzen ich wollte aber vorher
noch was sagen zum minister sparen nur
als beispiel ja ich habe jetzt seit märz
in baden-württemberg immer wieder das
sozialministerium angerufen ständig bin
ich da abgeprallt mit den schnellsten
mit den pcs mit dem schnelltest die
ganze zeit ja ich habe es erste mal
kontakt zum minister sparen vor
zweieinhalb wochen gehabt und anderthalb
wochen später hat er mich sofort nach
berlin dazu geholt und hat auch auf mich
gehört und hat auch einen teil davon
versucht jetzt umzusetzen oder versucht
es also zumindest da kam dann schon
finde ich auch ein interesse an einem
weg den ich in baden württemberg seit
über einem halben jahr versucht
klarzumachen
und ich mache eigentlich eher die länder
für sowas verantwortlich weil die
überschaubarer sind weil man hätte ganz
früh auch schon tests
schnelltests für altersheime besorgen
können ja und ich habe das damals im
oktober gesagt nur als beispiel ja
sofort die altersfrage mit schnelltest
besonders soll des altersheims selber
machen und es nur auf die kommunen zu
schieben geht nicht immer weil damals
und das ist noch ein beispiel für den
den vorhin damals war es tatsächlich so
dass dann die altersarmut bei mir
angerufen haben gesagt entweder es gibt
gar keine chance mehr die signale vom
markt gerade oder sie sind so teuer dass
wir uns das nicht leisten können
deswegen muss schon auch eine regierung
bestimmte sachen in die hand nehmen
zumindest die finanzierung und
vielleicht dann auch mit einem anderen
preis solche tests kaufen ja wir sind
das ist das war ja noch mal soll er
vollständig wollt noch was zu ihr und
sparen so ganz kurz da man kann ich eine
verantwortung bei ihm abladen es ist
völlig klar aber es wurden sehr sehr
teure masken eingekauft von teilweise
sehr minderer qualität es wurden
millionen bis milliarden ausgegeben für
fälschungs fälschungssichere
berechtigungsausweis stadt direkt die
masken zu verschicken et cetera pp also
es sind dort schon auch handwerkliche
fehler gemacht worden und ich hoffe eben
dass wir in zukunft etwas mehr vernunft
haben und die gesamtperspektive im blick
haben und in keinem lockdown
fundamentalismus verfallen gut diese
vernunft können den morgen ihren ersten
richtigen arbeitstag haben nach der nach
dem gipfel im kanzleramt das werden wir
hier in der phoenix runde auch genau
beobachten ich bedanke mich bei lisa
federle bei professor thorsten lea bei
georg streiter und bei alexander kissler
liebe zuschauer
ich habe es gesagt morgen in der phoenix
runde der korona gipfel morgen wieder so
eine art d-day in der deutschen
innenpolitik und wir stellen die frage
deutschland vor dem kurswechsel
live bei phoenix am mittwoch jetzt folgt
felix der tag mit thomas bade darin die
themen werden sie kennen
pressekonferenzen der
ministerpräsidenten laschet und daniel
günther aus schleswig holstein
warum das morgen warten wenn man auch
heute schon pressekonferenzen zum corona
gipfel morgen geben kann sie sehen es
lohnt sich
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]